Their major issue is reliability, which we've alluded to already.
We have a complex system that has multiple pieces to it and
that means a piece might go down, or might, be overloaded at,
at some particular point and how does the rest of the system, respond to that.
Overall we can call that a reliability question.
That is what percentage of the time is the overall application providing the,
the services that it should be providing. Typically you learn about
a reliability problem when some message that is sent is not delivered. Or
at least you don't get an acknowledgment back from it.
When strategy is to try sending the message again. The danger there of
course is that the, recipient receives two copies of the message,
and does whatever action is doing twice which also may be a problem.
This is an example of a classic reliability performance tradeoff.
That is. Whenever you use replication that's going to take more time and
more resources, as well as, as, as compromising the integrity of the system.
You can do it faster but it may not be as reliable. Various policies for
dealing with reliabilities use have arisen such as the,
the client making its best effort. The client's saying it will do at most once,
as far as message sending, at least once, exactly once and so on.